you may not know it but a film starring
Jeff gold Blum Gina Davis and Jim Carrey
hit theaters in 1989 and completely
bombed Earth Girls Are Easy built around
a song by Julie Brown is an 80s comedy
about a valley girl who befriends three
furry aliens after their spaceship
crashes into her pool once shaven the
fuzzy aliens become attractive men Earth
girl rezy was positively received by
critics upon release but hardly anyone
bothered to see it the film's estimated
budget of $10 million made the $3.9
million it earned at the box office a
tough pill to swallow well most people
missed out on seeing Earth Girls Are
Easy in theater it blew up via the home
rental market and televised broadcasts
Comedy Central also aired the film
throughout the '90s and 2000s ensuring
more people watched it it's now settled
nicely into the realm of cult classics
beloved for its pure camp absurdity with
multiple musical numbers that show
nobody took anything too seriously
making it